[Music]
this is another pattern I'd quite like
with Thai tetras
it's a teaspoon fountain that triquetra
version this came up recently maybe in
my life broadcast again you need to be
dialing your triquetra pretty well and
if you want general you spin
skillfulness consider my online course I
put a lot into that course but let's
assume you've got some triquetra skill
and the way I do this pattern it's
sideways tech trick address so I'm going
to do it with both my ploy going
clockwise and my right poi is going to
make a triquetra pointing across my body
boom so it pulls up my storm points up
my sternum point up my sternum point of
my sternum point my left PO is gonna go
down my sternum point down point down my
sternum Point Tower you think down my
centerline point down my centerline
point again the hard part is getting the
triquetra z' smooth enough technically
learning the pattern if that high
cutters are good isn't so hard because
all it really needs is a good switchy
switchy so it's you switch ii also in my
online course is or I've got the
plugging split time same direction and
I'm just switching which one's inside
and there's many approaches you can take
to this right now we're just going to do
one pass of each left right left right
and I've got my poi a little bit
holographic they're actually both bent
in towards me a little bit that's a
secret to all this stuff now what I have
to do is as the right poise coming up
inside my left arm I have to raise up a
bit
that's my left boys going down inside my
right arm I have to drop down and I just
do one of each right left right left
right left so you could even start just
like this and then as the Wrights coming
up I reach off to the right and as the
left is coming down I reach to the left
right up left down Matt use a triquetra
if you spin butts off fountain it's in
spin correlates is actually won in spin
with each booth right and summon with
the left it's bright and smooth left and
doing a hybrid looks very weird hope
that makes sense let me know like I've
been saying I'm setting off to produce a
lot of content in the coming months
while you know we're all going for this
pandemic thing a lot more fun motivating
for me if you interact if you share the
videos and of course it's awesome if you
become a patron of my patron account but
just having your feedback knowing you're
there and when you're watching knowing
you're sharing it makes a lot more
motivating for me so that's today's
lesson I'll be back with more
[Music]